would you rather give up porn or sex i  mean porn dude for one year  not even a [ __ ] question  i don't give a [ __ ] i'll beat off to my  imagination  that's kind of fun you know  i'll think about my [ __ ] sixth grade  biology teacher for a year there are  some good looking teachers and it  they're the one one of the ugliest  teachers in my high school had  truly a cartoonishly large ass  that would be funny just like i'm  talking like i'll be like this  and that would be pretty funny just to  feel  just i don't even think my dick could  get past an ass that big yeah yeah yeah  yeah i'm still thinking i looked up on  facebook a couple years ago time hasn't  been nice to her but but i'm still in  there yeah yeah